I'M "SNL'S" AIDY BRYANT.
YOU KNOW, OVER MY TEN YEARS ON
THE SHOW, I HAVE PLAYED DOZENS
OF TEACHERS, PRINCIPALS,
MOTHERS, WOMEN NAMED DIANE,
SUSAN, OR TEACHER.
AND I HAVE LOVED ALL OF THESE
SWEET, NURTURING WOMEN.
BUT THE SHOW SAID THAT IF I
PLAYED 150 OF THEM, THEN AS A
REWARD I COULD WRITE A SKETCH OF
MY OWN CHOOSING.
YOU KNOW, TO SHOW A DIFFERENT
SIDE OF MYSELF.
SO TONIGHT, THIS IS THAT SKETCH.
ENJOY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> I'M SO NERVOUS, I CAN'T
BELIEVE SIEGFRIED'S GOING TO
TAKE ME, A LOSER AND A FOOL.
HOW DO I LOOK?
>> YOU LOOK FANTASTIC, SIR.
I'M SURE SHE'LL BE TITILLATED.
>> BUT YOU'RE RIGHT TO BE
SCARED.
SHE IS THE MOST WIDELY DESIRED
WOMAN IN THE WORLD.
>> OH, I'M SICK.
I'M SICK WITH FEELING FOR THIS
WOMAN.
[ DOORBELL ]
IT'S HER.
PRAY FOR ME BOYS.
♪♪
>> HELLO.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
NOW, SCRAM, BOYS, AND LEAVE THIS
MAN TO ME.
>> MY GOD.
YOU ARE SO BEAUTIFUL.
AND SEXUAL.
AND I CAN TELL YOUR
PERSONALITY'S ALSO REALLY GOOD.
>> OH GOD, IF I HAD A NICKEL FOR
EVERY TIME I HEARD A MAN SAY
THAT, I WOULD HAVE SO MANY COINS
THAT IT WOULD BE ANNOYING.
>> OH, SENSUAL WOMAN.
YOU MAKE ME SO HORNY.
I SEE WHY THEY CALL YOU THE
SEXUAL WOMAN.
>> SO YEAH, I LIED TO
OSCAR ISAAC.
I TOLD HIM I HAVE A FAMOUS
RECURRING CHARACTER ON THE SHOW
CALLED "THE SEXUAL WOMAN."
IS THAT A CRIME?
♪♪
>> OH, I'M THE LUCKIEST MAN ON
EARTH TO BE BRUSHING YOUR HAIR.
MIND IF I GET A LITTLE CLOSER?
>> OH, SURE.
BRING YOUR HEAD AND BODY THAT
LOOK LIKE THAT CLOSER TO ME,
WHATEVER.
I DON'T CARE.
>> I NEED YOU TO KNOW, I SEE YOU
SEXUALLY.
I DON'T SEE YOU AS SOMEONE WHO
WOULD, LIKE, RUN A SCHOOL.
I MEAN, YOU ARE THE MOST UNDER
35 PERSON I'VE EVER MET.
>> OH, STOP IT, YOU FLIRT.
>> WELL, I BET YOU WERE ABOUT TO
DO YOUR BIG CATCHPHRASE.
>> UH -- OH, RIGHT.
YES.
MY FAMOUS CATCHPHRASE.
OF COURSE.
WHAT WAS IT?
HERE WE GO.
HEY, GET YOUR FAT ASS ON MY LAP,
BITCH!
>> OKAY.
YES.
>> OOH.
>> I MUST CONFESS, I HAVE A BIG
I MUST CONFESS, I HAVE A BIG,
COOL BONER RIGHT NOW WHICH I
SOMETIMES GET WHEN I RESPECT
SOMEONE TOO MUCH.
>> NOW, WHY DID I CHOOSE
OSCAR ISAAC FOR THE SKETCH?
NO REASON.
I MEAN, PRETTY RANDOM.
EVERY TIME I'VE DONE SOMETHING
ROMANTIC ON THE SHOW, IT'S BEEN
TOTALLY RANDOM.
LIKE WITH RYAN GOSLING.
OR DRAKE.
OH, MY GOD.
DO I HAVE A PATTERN OF SEXUAL
RANDOMNESS?
WELL, WHATEVER.
YOU ONLY LIVE ONCE.
NOW BACK TO THE SKETCH.
>> IS THE FOOD ALL RIGHT?
I HOPE YOU EVEN LIKE SPAGHETTI.
>> YOU'RE LUCKY THAT I DO.
>> DAMN IT, I'M IN LOVE WITH YOU
AND IT'S KILLING ME!
>> OH!
YES.
TO ME THIS IS NORMAL BEHAVIOR.
>> I WROTE A SONG FOR YOU, IF
THAT'S OKAY.
♪♪
♪ SEXUAL WOMAN ARE YOU FROM
PARIS OR BARCELONA ♪
♪ NO I'M FROM ARIZONA ♪
♪ SEXUAL WOMAN I RESPECT YOU
SO MUCH I'VE JUST
DEMONSTRATED BY MY INSANE
BONER ♪
>> OH.
A BONER?
LET ME GUESS.
YOU WANT TO KISS ME NOW.
>> YES, I DO.
BUT NOT YET.
YOU NEED TIME TO DIGEST ALL THAT
SPAGHETTI.
SO NOW COULD WE JUST HUG?
>> YES, GOOD IDEA.
I WOULD HAVE FORGOTTEN TO DIGEST
AND REGRETTED IT LATER.
>> OH, WHAT THEY SAY ABOUT YOU
IS TRUE.
YOU ARE EVERYONE'S CUP OF TEA.
INCLUDING ME, OSCAR ISAAC.
>> OH, I KNOW, OSCAR ISAAC.
>> SORRY.
IS THAT -- IT SAYS MY REAL NAME
ON THE CARD.
IS THAT A MISTAKE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I GUESS -- THE WRITERS ARE SO
ANNOYING AND STUPID.
I WOULD SAY I GUESS JUSTIFY GO
WITH IT?
>> OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
THEN LET'S GET MY FAT ASS ON
YOUR LAP.
>> YES.
♪♪